en fait à Paris il y a beaucoup
d'endroits qu'on peut escalader
il suffit d'y aller quoi c'est ça
on passe maintenant à notre carrière du
samedi 20
[Musique]
Simon Noguera bonsoir
vous pratiquez une discipline appelée le
freerun et le freerun c'est ça
[Musique]
voilà
alors Simon vous êtes né le 30 juillet
1993 à Étampes dans l'Essonne vous
grandissez à Saint-Chéron une commune de
4000 habitants à quelques stations de
RER de Paris votre père est policier et
votre mère est chef d'entreprise alors
dans la famille Negra on aime l'escalade
on va en weekend à Fontainebleau et
pendant les vacances on va dans les
gorges du Verdon et c'est comme ça que
vous commencez à apprivoiser le vide
très très jeune ça vous fait pas peur
c'est bien c'est sympathique
vous escaladez tout ce que vous trouvez
en 1998 vous venez de fêter vos cinq ans
vous tombez sur un reportage de Stade 2
consacré à David bel et vous dites il
sautait partout d'un immeuble à l'autre
d'une cage d'escalier à l'autre c'était
magnifique ça a été le tournant de votre
vie ouais c'est ça qui m'a donné envie
de David Bell exact effectivement après
le breakdance le rap le graffiti les
banlieues parisiennes découvrent ce
qu'on appelle à l'époque le parcours
alors le principe c'est au lieu de
prendre les escaliers on saute au lieu
de passer par la porte on passe par la
fenêtre et il faut aller le plus vite
possible voilà c'est le parcours c'est
le projet de l'utilité dans le concept
du déplacement donc c'est être efficace
il y a un film qui s'appelle
Yamakasi qui fait 2 millions et demi
d'entrée en 2001 qui raconte un peu
effectivement ce qu'est le parcours
alors c'est vers 13 ans que vous essayez
se reproduire pour la première fois les
cascades de vos idoles sur Youtube vous
découvrirez un tuto pour réaliser le
fameux wallflip alors c'est quoi le Wolf
flip alors le concept de ce mouvement
c'est de courir au sol de mettre un pied
contre le mur de faire un salto arrière
la première fois vous prenez une grosse
vôtre quand même seulement j'ai pris
j'ai pris des j'ai pris des grosses
gamelles parfois vous blessez vraiment
un jour vous tentez un saut de chat au
dessus d'une barrière mais votre main
droite se dérobe vous retrouvez aux
urgences avec les côtes cassées c'est
quoi un saut de chaleur il y a un
obstacle en l'occurrence c'était une
barrière et le projet c'est de sauter de
poser ses mains et puis passer les
jambes entre ses mains voilà ça c'est
pas passé comme ça
[Rires]
alors bien sûr les profs gueule
il faut dire que vous êtes passé très
rapidement au stade supérieur vos
cascades prennent de la hauteur et vous
balader sur les toiles voilà c'est ça
vers quel âge si aux alentours à mon
avis des 16 17 ans que je commence à
prendre un petit peu de hauteur
physiquement là vous commencez à
entraîner des potes avec vous direction
Paris et là vous découvrez le plaisir de
vous balader dans des endroits où jamais
personne n'a mis les pieds vous avez
fait quoi comme comme immeuble à Paris
au départ au départ c'était surtout la
défense la défense c'est assez
architectural il y a beaucoup de
hauteurs et du coup ça c'est intéressant
et puis les terrasses ça terrasses
boldieu entre autres entre les immeubles
et au début c'était surtout la défense
ou Bercy le paléonisport de Bercy est
assez accessible au commun des mortels
aussi c'est une c'est une pente comme ça
donc c'était facile de monter dessus en
fait à Paris il y a beaucoup d'endroits
qu'on peut escalader
[Musique]
alors avec vos potes vous créez la
french Free Run family là c'est plus le
parcours tel que vous l'aviez fait au
départ ça devait artistique c'est-à-dire
que il faut aller le plus vite possible
mais il faut aussi que ça soit beau
exacte c'est ça alors c'est mon ami
Yoann Le Roux qui a créé cette cette ce
groupe en 2009 et en effet depuis on
évolue dans le milieu artistique plus
que dans le milieu
plus que dans le parcours et la
performance exactement et là vous
achetez des caméras embarquées des GoPro
vous n'avez jamais le vertige vous non
jamais eu très très peur
maintenant le danger existe j'ai
conscience du danger au même titre que
vous mais mais le danger volatile
c'est terrible vertige le vide vous
attire non jamais il m'a attiré
j'ai pas le vertige j'avais peur et
c'est cette peur qui vous qui vous
maintient en vie en fait avec
complètement c'est cette peur là que je
peux juger mes capacités que je ne les
dépasse pas et que justement je les
apprivoise alors à 19 ans vous décrochez
un bac pro vente quand même hein mais
bon parallèlement sur Internet vous
exploit comment ça fait le buzz et un
jour vous commencez à être contacté par
des marques pour faire des spots de pub
alors il y a red Bull il y a Renault il
y avait littifer reste que vous
activités Simon ne sont pas légales les
flics vous arrêtent tout le temps et en
ce moment avec le plan Vigipirate ça
doit être très marrant non on évite
d'aller trop trop ou d'aller ou de se
faire remarquer en règle générale là
c'est le bac alors l'autre problème
c'est vos parents Vous habitez toujours
chez vos parents là je suis chez mes
parents voilà et votre maman la pauvre
elle fait des cauchemars toutes les
nuits c'est normal elle est cauchemars
en effet c'est une maman pendant
longtemps elle vous a demandé d'arrêter
et puis elle a compris que en fait vous
pouviez pas vous en passer de ce truc là
c'est ce qui me construit c'est ce qui
c'est ce qui me fait c'est ce qui me
fait vivre je me sens au travers de ça
je me trouve au travers de mes capacités
et puis de ce que je recherche et donc
voilà je l'a compris on va regarder
maman Noguera
[Musique]
je suis
admirative de mes enfants mais bien sûr
en tant que maman te voir dans des
vidéos où tu prends des risques qui pour
moi sont exagérées c'est très dur pour
le décompte à l'estomac là ça m'inquiète
ça m'inquiète beaucoup donc voilà le
message que j'ai à te faire passer c'est
je t'aime très très fort et je te fais
des très très gros bisous réalise-toi
nique la prise de risque
voilà
le prochain défi c'est quoi Simon la
Tour Eiffel j'aimerais bien mais pas pas
en période de Vigipirate je pense que
j'ai évité peut-être plus tard peut-être
plus tard mais à part les films de
Besson on a quoi comme des bouchers
[Applaudissements]
à est un professionnel extrêmement
entraîné physiquement mentalement et
n'essayez pas reproduire vous c'est que
vous venez de voir
[Rires]
et pour être sûr de ne rien rater de
Inna larditude abonnez-vous et mettez un
pouce bleu